[Music]
would you like to introduce yourself to
the group
I'm the Prince of Malaysia
some call me The Dark One
other as the Lord of death
however
to most
I am known simply as
Phil's boss
I am
Dracula okay obviously we're dealing
with a little bit more than just
narcissism here
Mr Fernfield welcome
I
am
actually we will make a very good
assistant no he's evil we will protect
you you have the word of the most
trusted institution on Earth the
Catholic Church
oh
friend Hill your sole purpose in life is
to serve me now let's see
I just want a normal life again
God bless you Mr Renfield oh God bless
you nuns you're a hero Robert Montague
Renfield
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me The
Dark One
of death so you bring and people to eat
well I do other stuff like what washes
cake no the Cape is dry clean only
strictly yeah I will wear this it's fly
yeah
we got nothing such a bad guy but you're
never really gonna be free until you
face him I will no longer tolerate abuse
I deserve happiness
okay you deserve only suffering I will
Unleashed everyone you care about will
suffer because if you trade me we have
to stop him Before Sunset
[Music]
foreign
ER I deserve happiness and I take full
charge
[Music]
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is gonna be my way worse it's my least
favorite part of the job
[Music]
foreign